so you charge the phone right with the
cable yes what if I could tell you we
could modify that cable so when it's
plugged into your computer that we could
remotely command the cable to install
malware on your computer the cable the
cable itself how do you get the cable to
the victim well if you have on-site
access you're in a company and you can
swap it out or we could do what we call
a social engineering attack and send a
device with a cable we plugged in the
cable and now what the attacker is going
to do is command the cable to install
malware malicious software on the
computer so the hacker has complete
control I could push a button on here in
about five seconds you're going to see
it like magically tight
it's going to be a split second and then
what's going to happen over here we're
going to gain control of the computer
there it goes that's the malware being
injected and I just happened that fast
that fast so right now you're
controlling this computer from Virginia
that could turn on the victim's webcam
and now I can spy on you